what i've been confused about for my  whole career is why people get away from  the trenches why they become so  about meetings and boardrooms and lose  touch with what actual human beings do  why they begin to believe reports that  are fake over their own  common sense intuition and what they  believe as a human being this is foreign  for the entrepreneurs in the room  because you have no choice you have to  pay attention to what the customer's  doing that's how you eat it is  incredibly real i'm watching some of the  faces in front of me for the people that  are in the trenches in corporate  environments i know why they do it it's  the currency of their organization it's  how bonuses get done it's how everyone  is scored these reports are broken we  must go into the next decade becoming  more consumer-centric and more common  sense oriented